[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la musique c'est une catastrophe
on dirait frère on dirait qu'en France 3
ils veulent retransmettre des matchs de
foot
[Applaudissements]
et Philippe
je suis content de vous voir nous aussi
j'ai failli
tu sais ça va vite hein
dis-moi je suis passé un truc tout à
l'heure j'ai quand même failli jouer
dans toutes les films
tu as choisi une carrière à la
télévision qui marche plutôt pas mal on
va pas se mentir
aux besoins de ta famille de façon assez
modeste
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tes enfants n'ont pas de jet privé
des vacances avec lui
je vais raconter c'est un fou il m'a
pris pour un supermarché il m'a pris
pour une supérette
il avait la maison à côté toute la
journée
il revient 2 minutes après tu as pas un
torchon parce que j'aurais su un truc
faut savoir une chose c'est qu'il a eu
un bunker chez lui il y a un garage avec
une palette de Cocagne palette de Red
Bulls
j'ouvrais la porte comme ça
la première fois que je viens chez lui
je vous jure qu'il y a quelqu'un qui
passe et c'est et c'est pas qui c'est si
c'est un politique mais politique et
j'entends non donc c'est lui et il y a
un coup d'Arc qui passe et qui tire le
politique dans les fesses tout est réel
il arrive avec le bras dans le plâtre il
fait ça mon chéri j'ai dit mais tout se
passe il dit bah là je tire à l'arc sur
le ministre
[Applaudissements]
une connerie j'ai pris le vélo de mon
fils je suis allé dans une descente et
je me suis mangé un trou il s'est ouvert
la main il avait la main complètement
cassée
[Applaudissements]
le jeu qu'on faisait parce qu'il a vu
après
celui qui perdait des flèches dans le
cul je vous jure que c'est vrai
chez toi à Cannes pendant que nous on
les paye pour être au ministère
attention
comment ça va toi et ben écoute
ça va pas mal content de te voir
avec des potes avec un ministre
je parlais de toi tout à l'heure je te
jure si tu es content de te voir tu vois
je prends pas beaucoup d'invités
maintenant oui j'ai vu ouais je prends
vraiment les vraiment les potes vraiment
très très bien parce que vous avez autre
chose à faire aussi puis tu en as tu en
as 10 tous les soirs
pas ouais
parce que si tu devais venir que des
invités ça te coûterait moins cher et là
c'est fait on va voir la bande alors
c'est ce que je vous propose ce que vous
êtes des potes
la prochaine fois que je serai pas là
ils sont devenus gentils non il faut les
augmenter
moi j'ai vu parce que je sais parce que
je sais c'est parce que tu sais pas ce
que c'est que ma vie toi tu sais pas ce
que c'est que ma vie toi 600 balles quoi
600 balles c'est énorme ils viennent
tous les jours ou pas il y en a partout
à la Torah
prévoit ce qu'ils vont dire qui étudie
les dossiers arrête c'est énorme boulot
qui sont obligés de venir entre deux
trucs et toi 600 600 francs
il a raison est-ce que tu fais
aujourd'hui moi je veux plus de gilet
jaune
je vais dire la vérité et tu me connais
bien
tu connais pas ma vie tu mets des tu
connais pas ma vie